[Musique]
des premières résolutions
c'est un peu fumé je pense que je trouve
que c'est pas bon pour la santé
et quand on fait deux heures de
spectacle il faut être raisonnable
donc je ne fume plus épidermique oui
c'est à dire j'ai quand même j'ai plus
souvent qu'avant
d'ailleurs ça se voit si le film exprès
pour voir si j'ai encore du sou c'est ça
c'est pour ça parce que je sais je vois
vous riez déjà pourriez pas ce que vous
dites ce type d'agriculture il est en
train de fumer mais c'est un contrôle
c'est tout je contrôle parce que comment
voulez-vous je contrôle mon souffle
ça se voit pas à l'ordre le club voilà
c'est tout des résolutions une des
résolutions des genres et d'autres gens
mais d'autres là par exemple j'ai pris
la résolution de ne plus faire trop
grimace parce que je suis doué sur le
plan de la grimace jeu solide ou et mais
quand même c'est pas trés ce n'est pas
du grand art la grimace quand même quand
on commence à perdre il est mal c'est
qu'on n'a pas autre chose à peine la
place grimace rien rien ça c'est du
grand art c'est de ne rien faire du tout
[Musique]